I miss Sahana and I'm from Sunnyvale  California and I recently saw a video  this is you Steven view and John singing  do you want to build a snowman on no  hein and I'm a singer myself and I was  wondering if you would ever ashamed to  share your singing talents with us on  the show  I mean Oh on the show yeah or no  [Applause]  do it  [Applause]  [Music]  go ahead  and say what  [Laughter]  you  not a lot of people have seen him with  it it's very hard anyway goes on and on  and on but everybody last time ready one  two three four go  you  ah  our our apologies to the one pulpit  wonderful we would like to apologize to  lin-manuel Miranda yes butchering is  eating on stage and they will never ever  ever ever ever never ever be a musical  episode on show but but we want a  musical on the CW yeah can I actually  want to ask the audience something will  you guys help me sing something really  quick Emily two three  [Music]  [Applause]  you